[Music]
what the hell get out of
here nice way to save py good job good
job buddy all right how's it going bros
my name is I am [__] by these [__]
creatures all right how you doing I'm
just going to go here all right good we
open a red door in the last episode I
don't know where the [__] they more of
them they never stop coming do they oh
Jesus Christ all right I remember when
here oh wait oh it's here why of course
hey pills and all that kind of stuff
ah that wasn't did someone just try to
touch my nipples through the hole
why would they do that it hurt it hurt
oh no I out
batteries all right let's save the game
and then oh no let's not go there Reuben
what are you doing here I told you to
get the [__] out of my house Reuben have
we already clicked it yeah we did maybe
it's in
here and it's kind of difficult cuz I
can't see [__] let's do it save all
right okay there's we can go here
that's such a good
tactic oh I'm here got to be here
then no I can't go anywhere this is dead
end why would they do
that what is this
place I don't understand it's a trap all
right thing is I need to get rid of you
can we chop him
ah all right buddy it's cool I don't I
don't know how the hell you fit in here
you are [__] huge all right let's try
that again all right what am I all right
all right the shotgun don't waste the
deagle Bey hey bro hey how you doing how
you
doing you're
dead now you're dead how many [__]
shots do you need Jesus Christ those are
[__] tanks all right all right
buddies all right sweet I see you
later
all right I think it's oh no it's not in
here hey stop following me around hey I
found
keys and where do the keys go to oh no
this is not
good [__]
ah all right all right all right all
right it's cool it's cool no it's not
cool maybe this is this door hey I found
ammo sweet sweet sweet baby Jesus okay
all right all right stop following
they're so mean why what did I ever
do but where where am I supposed to go
maybe it wasn't up in here after
all why did
I where where where buddies where brush
all right hey pills
sweet I'm [__]
rich [__] I said it I said it all right
I heard something I always hear
something
okay okay it's all right just jump the
car Speedy that's what hey it's here all
right
cool just have to
wait where am I going I'll never know
okay is there something oh here it
is this place is horrible I really need
batteries really
effing no I already did this [__]
great my
memory what wins again chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop now we're back
here now we
go ah I'm so awesome with finding okay
it's not here don't walk too fast you
followed me why would you do that
seriously [__]
stalker that was four shots you should
be dead thank you very much oh no ah
come come
on
where a are you kidding
me now whatever we progress at least be
happy feel all right s
what what is that hey oh no it's those
little sperm shooting [__] how should
we deal with
him let's just run like a
[__] oh oh go oh oh we're
here all right fine hey how you doing
all right see you later
buddy
yes I'm progressing David Le hofs change
name to derish Pro there oh no I went
back okay here we
go all right this way through there all
right hey this is bright I like this
first time in the many years I'm in
heaven chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop yes chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop oh it feels so good
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop I like that chop
chop chop chop chop chop oh look at this
chop chop chop someone trying to WRA me
chopping chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop heang nothing ch ch
ch o more DRS nearly full health how was
it possible oh man I'm getting good as
it no I'm not I've been having like
three Health oh oh no I don't trust this
it's time to bring out the big
guns what is this
hello hello anyone in
here
hello all
right oh oh no oh it was so nice in here
a oh
hello anyone down
here all I'm just going
to okay we're good we're good they're
[__] everywhere
[Music]
okay swim swim swim buddy swim swim it's
this water it's disgusting blah blah
blah oh no it's oh no I I can't I can't
okay I might as well drown myself I know
never how do I even I don't even know
anymore H jump if you ever jump before
Oh no I have to
swim I don't like this I don't like this
I don't like this at all I like this oh
I can walk here all
right all right we're again F6
[__] F [__] six it's
blocked from the other
penis I don't like you buddy oh no no no
no no no let me change weapon let me
change
weapon I told it to change weapon you
never listen to you zombies zombies
never listen very I like I used to date
the zombie girl once she it was all talk
they never what all right oh look at
this just look at it I won want to look
anymore not looking anymore okay I get
it it's your things I wasted the eagle
shot damn that did a lot of
damage back off thank
you all right where were we all right
yes now I remember F6 [__] I
don't know why I call you [__]
I'm sorry let's aim this very
nice come on I'm wasting ammo
here oh okay so I can't do it all right
lesson learn lesson
learn lesson Leal that made no sense I
don't know why I said that all right
let's read this day terator is on the
third floor hey Budd why you trying to
pull ah oh you can't
pass how's that feel how does that feel
tell me oh you're
disappearing all right we are cooler
than Mr Cool all right just need to find
the Detonator on the third floor the
lock is missing it by of course I like
this part does nothing all right
[Music]
sweet third floor why the oh I need to
go back
maybe I don't know I didn't inv that
this all right H CH I made it that was
freaking MLG
jump okay did we check here yes we did
hey a hammer holy [__] smack smack smack
smack smack smack this is awesome I have
a freaking Hammer oh [__] better
recognize
[__] no no I I lose my oh the Dilemma
oh the Dilemma the chop knife or the
smash Hammer I'll
Never back off stupid all right maybe
works here all right MLG
360 oh no I fell down oh whatever all
right buddy all right buddy all right
all right you can do it for me and
for oh and I charge I chargeing my
hammer all right it doesn't
work God damn it maybe
here what the hell is the hammer for
it's not hammer time that's for chisel
all right I did it again let's try back
here what are you doing here
buddy oh no back off thank you all right
good job maybe here let's smack the
smack it oh didn't work maybe if you
crouch smack it
smoth didn't
work hey what is this I miss this cool
okay third floor
un all right got through whatever what
is it ah Charlie what are you doing
here Charlie don't make me do it don't
back off back
off I tell you the back off Jesus Christ
I'm Sorry Charlie you must
die for
science
yes [__] you
Charlie [__] all of you hey what is this
milk nice acetone what about this can we
chop it can we chop acetone no we can't
hey what yes SMG [__]
yeah Reuben oh
no ah St you see that Dodge you flew
like a mother like your mother Once Dead
you would make your mother proud Reuben
I'm sorry she's dead I raped your mother
all right let's smash this ah didn't
work fine I'm taking this with
me I don't even care can we get this in
here what is this for oh over there all
right all right buddy come on come on do
it for science do it for science I tell
you come on come all right all right all
right we're cool we're
cool all
right sham [__] sham works too all
right one shot smash that's that's what
I'm talking
about all right we got the
smash I don't know I prefer chopping I I
I I can't I can't lie I I I don't know
why I would lie about that but
anyway smash all right let's go in
here and
here and oh no there's blood what did I
wait what's the point of this place oh I
need to go up here right
probably yeah there all right anyway we
we're going to do it in the next episode
like and favorite if you enjoyed
subscribe click that thing to gra a bro
today seriously though any one reason
why you wouldn't do it oh okay two
reasons why you would ah okay I'm just
gonna end you I'm just kid of course you
really click anyway like
[Music]
see telep
bring
me okay [__] don't make love in front of
me Jesus Christ I get that you're gay
and all but ah not in front of me